welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is
hisham azuz today i'm very excited to be
joined by
a chat called mark nealon who actively
invests
in recruitment startups and is on the
mission
to help 50 recruiting entrepreneurs
maximize their potential
and previous to mark doing this and mark
was one of the owners
of finley james mark thanks for joining
me
hello thanks for having me and for those
that can't see
mark you're wearing a fruity nice fruity
shirt mate
well you know it's not quite a beta but
that's what
happened so i thought i'd bring a bit of
a beaker to
let me just start with how um how have
things been for you over the last
couple of months what's been going on in
your world how things been
i'd say all right now is the short
answer
um you know with a lot of touching wood
um just just mad as you know i think um
there was that
crazy bit at the start where lockdown
came in
and uh everybody had to deal with that
very very quickly and so there's the
there's
getting over the shot myself uh to begin
with but then helping the people
i invest in to uh
fully enough i could maybe a story
around that get get off the beach was
kind of the
tagline get off the beach yeah
yeah um all right we'll give you a story
straight away yeah let's go let's do it
let's do it get off the beach talk to me
all right so anybody i invest in will
know what get off the beach means
right so that's i i i like um for my
sins
i i've always liked um military history
so uh love uh reading about d-day
i've been over to normandy only a couple
of years ago and there's a fella
there's a guy that i'm not sure have you
ever heard of a guy called norman coter
general norman coater all right um
general norman colter sprang to my mind
the day after lockdown
because um he was he was in his late 50s
and he was the highest ranking general
that actually went
uh in with the troops with the americans
onto omaha beach
and um he was in the second wave but so
by the time he got there
you know very very bad situation people
getting wiped out all over the place and
basically the american gi's
were pinned by you know just kind of
hide behind anything
anything they could find and they were
all basically
you know just terrified and not moving
so what does he do
he gets there i think three people got
wiped out as he got off the landing
craft
and he's basically just stood up
basically walking around
uh and it what he was basically what was
it what was the quote that was
attributed to him
gentlemen there's only two types of uh
men on this beach
uh those that are dead and those that
are about to die so get off the
you know what beach and that was
the reason why that uh sprang to mind
and
how like what we were talking about that
a lot myself
and my investors in the early stages of
lockdown
is because when something that crazy
happens
shock kicks in so i think what you what
you can either do
is you can either freeze or you can keep
moving
yeah you freeze you're dead for sure if
you keep moving
you know at that time none of us knew
what what you know what was in store
good analogy yeah so it was get up it
was keep just keep moving get off the
beach get off the beach
and you know and uh they did they did
that very very
you know i i'm um i obviously i worked
with a lot of early stage smaller
businesses
and just couldn't be more proud of them
love that mark straight in there
military story i think no one's ever
started this podcast with a
military story analogy awesome yeah well
welcome to my welcome to my mind awesome
uh
but look how i always like to start this
show is uh yeah
how did mark nealon enter the world of
recruitment
let's just start with that story okay um
i answered that well my mum uh
was sick of me living with her and
paying no rent in the early 20s after
uni
and um where'd you live uh i lived i now
live in disburse south manchester
then it was also south manchester place
called eating more than the um
with my parents and um it was an advert
in the manchester evening
news very small advert and it said
honestly there's something like do you
want to win loads of money you might be
good at football
if so call this number that was it
so there you go they kind of hired the
uh they did identify the competencies
that they wanted
and um yeah applied to that and uh
fortunately
um got got got hired
and um you know that was the first of
two jobs i got um
sacked in in the first year in
recruitment
before i ended up at uh philly james you
mentioned them before that brees be well
known
uh to to start with i was uh the guy
making the brews
yeah guy making the brews and you know
one of two things happened ended up
owning half the business and
um you know reasonably successful uh
but yeah unemployable is probably one of
the words you would use to describe me
okay let let's unpack that then
so go into the industry which you've now
been in for what over 20 years
yeah around that yeah so enter the
industry
so yeah what ended up not keeping the
two jobs
the two first recruitment jobs no ended
up at finley james
and we're talking also so i've had
obviously as i'm saying i've had john
gaucho in a couple of times that people
should know and associate with finney
james
and so what i saw online just to frame
up for context is you work to uh was it
funny james for
13 years it looked like yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah so it's a really long
time
so let's just unpack that a bit so
firstly when so when you joined finney
james's
did you actually join him as a
consultant then or what was the yeah
so um my first job there i guess was
um it was business development you know
100 calls a day
done all that um i actually love all
that
stuff love all that a little bit yeah
yeah
love the business development side of
the game um
but that's yeah that's that that that's
what what did the business just talk
give me a paint a picture quickly like
what what did the business look like at
that point so we're talking what is it
like 2003
2003 yeah what did the business look
like how many people would you live
like what did the business look like at
that stage uh there's myself
uh and uh john
and then one to two other people
okay some really small business yeah
yeah um
but the business it was backed initially
by um
a vc uh didn't get off to the quickest
start and then for you know
one reason or another what ended up
happening was uh he kind of pulled out
other people left and it just ended up
being myself and john owen in half
business
okay cool so
what did that journey entail denmark
because
that's where it was started right but by
the time you left
just how people understand listening by
the time you left 30 years down the road
what what business did the what what did
finney james look like when you left
uh yeah multiple officers uh doing
business internationally
40 50 people um you know
successful successful business left a
successful business still a successful
business
um uh when
that that was from two blogs and a
couple of phones essentially in a very
you know what why do you think was that
why do you think he was able to
sort of up until he left why do you
think he was uh able to do that
um because a lot a lot of recruitment
has done get to that point
yeah but somebody told me this the other
day i can't know what the exact number
is but it's something like eight percent
also
that's it yeah um i i think
i think it's people it is people drive
teamwork um um
i think i think drive has a lot to do
with it um
you know your own personal drive as a
leader or
yeah yeah okay yeah
you've either got that or you haven't
haven't yet i think that's that's a
that's i think that's a blessing and a
curse at the same time and it's
something you've got to harness and
control
you know even um you know what
when you start off there's something
great about wanting to
rule the world you know metaphorically
um
you've got to do that in a safe way
right
were you talking about preventing sort
of burnout or yeah you know
but yeah the whole burnout thing i've
you know i've done that
drive people
yeah try to see you know you need good
people uh
drive and i think a lot of it that's
i it comes down to mindset so
um i've learned this probably
i've probably learned more about this
since leaving
uh finley james than
you yeah yeah i think i think you i
think a lot of
leaders have great natural mindset
and i think part of that is you've
either got that innate drive
in there or you haven't um
but i think also when it comes to the
culture of your business
um mindset is still
under rated yeah
and i think that's for leaders and for
the people in recruiting businesses
i think if you've only got a look at
what's happening now
uh you know all of a sudden there's a
lot of people you know really focusing
on mental health
and resilience is a buzzword
[Music]
uh something i've talked about a lot
recently which is
you know should resilience be something
that is
just expected or or you know
can you can we do it yeah yeah
um what um
what were some of the sort of biggest
learning strike mistakes
that you went through finney james
before you left
uh oh i mean do you just just
name all of them really but what comes
what comes up for you though when i ask
you that
do you think no doubt other people would
have to go through or
can expect and i would
say that you
need to have a really good plan
and you
[Music]
before you just go for growth have a
really good plan
before you take shitloads of action yeah
i think
a bit more strategy yeah otherwise you
can end up going for growth and then you
what can happen
before you finally get it right is you
get the whole deck of cards and can
implode implode before you you know but
that's that's part of the learning
process isn't it
about breaking things that you end up
getting it right yeah
in the end okay and
what did you did you seek any
like did you receive any good advice
while she was growing a recruitment
business
out of interest and i'd say a lot of it
for quite a long time actually was was
done
on a self-taught basis really uh
towards the end um we did have
uh a non a non-exec someone helping us
that was great
why was that great and because um
you can take shortcuts so you cannot you
can
i think that's the benefit of good
advice is
you can either spend ages working it out
yourself
or you can go to somebody else who has
paid what i call the entrance fees
you know and just you know i'd rather
i'd rather be
as much as i will say that mistakes are
good and that it's only by
making you know you you lie that you
never lose you either winner you learn
and uh as much as you learn from your
mistakes i'd rather
not make them if somebody can tell me
look do that and that's going to cost
you 20 grand
you know and i know that because when
you do that this happens and this
happens
i'd rather learn from other people's
mistakes and not make them
uh yeah and then then go and you know
do it the noble way make the mistake
yourself lose 20 grand and all the rest
of it so i think that's what a good
advisor will do they will
they'll um help you benefit from either
their mistakes
or just things that they know won't work
uh and uh you know that can accelerate
your journey
pay the entrance freeze i like that
entrance fees mate yeah i like that
i've paid a lot of them in fact most
i think most things that the people i
help get value from
are probably stories of things i've done
wrong i'm wrong
yeah interesting okay really keen to
talk about
your journey in sort of backing
recruiters and sort of the common things
you've seen
etc but how how hard how hard was it
just talk a bit about how hard it was
because i think people can relate to
this
like how hard was it for mark to to
leave a business that
dedicated a lot of time to no doubt
meant quite a bit to you
how hard was that making that decision
for you personally
yeah it was it was incredibly difficult
and at the same time
easy you know um
so the you know i think anybody who's
invested you know over a decade of the
life
into something and you've got you know
um
relationships uh and
bonds and all the rest of it you know
it's really it's really difficult
you know if you're if you're somebody
who puts the heart and soul into
something
then if you leave that then that's going
to um
impact you and it did um
but easy in the context of when you just
know when you know you know you know
when it's time to kind of get off the
bus
and go somewhere else it's time so
you've got to
yeah i think there's a but is that
friction though isn't it it's there's
that
yeah what you're talking about that
friction between you know but also
i'll put a lot into this yeah it's
it's how much you trust your instinct
and how much you back yourself
isn't it yeah you know and i think
i always think don't have any regrets
and
you know i'm i'm really big on like um
purpose and um uh
you know aligning to that kind of higher
purpose vision whatever you want to call
whatever you want to call it and you
know if it's just don't feel right
you got you've got to go and you've got
to keep moving you'll go somewhere else
it's just a matter of time doesn't it
because before it balls over or before
you get to a point where you may not
even be you be may even be more
unhappier than where you was
six months ago three months ago if you
if you don't listen to that and try and
bottle it up that's all innate yeah
sort of voice in your head from your
stomach whatever it may be going mark
i'm not sure this is right yeah okay but
the voice gets the voice gets louder
right there'll be people listening to
this now who aren't happy
yeah and if you're not if and if you if
you know the reasons that you're not
happy
and you the really strong you know you
know they're kind of not going to go
anywhere nothing's going to change
really you you know
they're just really strong feelings
then most of the time the thing that
stops us from acting on that is fear
yeah and i'd rather there must be so
many people out
out there who don't do anything about
it i think a lot of the time it's
because they're
you know same old reasons isn't it it's
money uh
you know i'll do it when this happens or
you know
we kind of bat it kick the can down the
road um
but i reckon that's i reckon that's more
dangerous in the long term because
you're
gonna end it's gonna end up eating you
alive
it's gonna gnaw away at you and you're
going to end up with regrets
so i'd rather always just think you know
go me on weight
listen to it's not it's it's more than
just instincts and
gut feeling it's things that you've
learned you know we know as recruiters
don't we that
you know things like you know counter
offers
you know once you want to leave once
you're probably going to want to leave
again
so once that uh genie
once you take the lid off the bottle you
know you kind of you know got to do
something about it or you'll end up
more unhappy if you don't that was my
way of thinking about it anyway so
it was it was very difficult and um
yeah it was quite quite scary at the
time actually yeah i can imagine
so just for context then mark final bit
of context really so and then and then
how long
how long has it been since you left
vinnie james um
it was about about
three three and a half years sometimes
three and a half years yeah cool
so let's just talk about those those
first 12 months after leaving
because no doubt that was difficult
right because
what as you said decade of your life you
knew what you had to do every day
and you had certain people in your life
for the last 10 years
all those things and all of us obviously
our choice obviously and
we're talking about why it was important
for you to make that choice and make
that jump but
yeah how was that first year for you
like how how difficult was it to get out
of that because i think that's again
we're talking about the part
that people are fearful of so what did
what was that first year like
uh in the end
uh in in the end it was all right but i
you know i probably
that i probably got pissed for about a
month i told that very few times
you know uh and then i thought i think
i think i stayed in my bed for about a
month you know that's the thing i was
literally uh yeah you know
it's weird actually because why oh i
just got
i just got really you know what there's
so much stuff going on
in your head you know you can't do
anything because you you know you
based that that's basically what you um
agree not you know you agree not to do
anything i didn't know what i wanted to
do to be
quite honest with you at that time um
i thought me and recruitment was done
you know and um
uh yeah just just feeling it because
how old was you at that point at that
time i would have been 38
exactly so that i think that's part of
it as well right 38 years you've been on
the planet by that point and you
yeah ended up getting yeah drinking
leaving obviously the the business is a
big part of
and it's like [ __ ] i'm 38 what the
[ __ ] do i do now
yeah you know done all right out of it
but you know this is the way i left the
business you just
not the way you leave a business it was
like [ __ ] this i'm off
basically yeah yeah yeah and uh
so that that would be another tale that
i would
tell any all the people i helped it
would be like listen this sound up this
is how not to do that
but that's life and it's like you know
the
uh everything like i'm honest honest to
god i'm like so
at the time it was i was just really
struggling to process things what i
realized looking back
is i wasn't educating myself
enough because i've become kind of sick
of the world and sick of this and sick
of that in one way
or another i wasn't developing you know
probably for the past
last few years there as as is my normal
way
and uh and that's
actually what ended up kind of um
getting get me moving again
he's just going back to basics and
rebuilding myself really and just
learning this that and the other
and uh yeah
um not i'm really grateful for that
time in my life now and now now i look
back at it
and it seems like what was a what was a
bothered about
why yeah but at the time it was all
consuming
and um so how did you get your head
above the wall because i feel like
people can relate to that
and may even find themselves in a
position now mark where
they've been on furlough for the last
six weeks 12 weeks and they've just been
told
hey mark unfortunately there's not gonna
be a job for you
whatever future you had unfortunately is
not there whatever it may be right i
feel like people
may be in that position or might find
themselves in that position so i guess
obviously you've said around what helped
you was recognized like you just started
to
spend time on yourself which is
something that you lacked but
yeah what helped you sort of looking
back what really helped you overcome
that
right i'm going to write a few things
down now so i mentioned so remember to
say these because there's a few
few things there was a few things right
let's do it a few things
right okay that one that one i want okay
right so i'll start with my mum
so very very lucky so uh
support network yeah but like you
wouldn't believe
so people think now oh yeah you know my
invest in recruiting businesses what
they don't realize
is that started with me and my mom
and my mum's saying come on man you can
do this what's up we are what's amazing
yeah where's me bygone you know uh
you know and that that was uh and you
know if it wasn't for her
kind of saying look believe it or not
yeah
yeah that so i think we all need a kind
of
uh we all need someone to kind of remind
us
that we're all right you know uh and to
keep going
the other stuff was kind of uh
some technical stuff some stuff i did
instinctively which was good
which was i just i don't i unfollowed
everybody within the network that had
anything to do with the company that
that
uh yeah so yeah so you you controlled
what was entering your world yeah yeah
so
that you recognized was ended up sort of
triggering thoughts or bad things yeah
yeah i realized that look that's nothing
against
anybody no of course anyone i just had
to look after my own
space yeah of course you know i left a
good business but it's no good to me
seeing how well they're doing every day
and lunch clubs and all the rest of it
that wasn't helping me you know so
i employed everybody including my
brother who worked there
you know when i left and uh sorry i am
fully unfollowed everybody
in including my brother who worked there
when i left and that was a really
that was a clever thing that i did
actually that helped me just
start putting one foot in front of the
other and get moving again
um and you know i think you know what
else what else
i just i just started lying i i started
surrounding myself
with all the really positive people and
i just focused on filling my mind
full of positive things and i was on him
um uh doctor have you ever heard of
doctor hannah
i think stock might be doctor anna she's
brilliant
she's a um uh a psychologist that helps
one of one or two of the people that i
help and she was good enough to go on a
webinar
with one of um my uh investees down the
other day and
what she was talking about was how to
pull yourself out of um
a negative brain loop actually reminding
yourself that
you've been in scrapes before and you
didn't quit
and that's the advice i think could be
helpful to anybody
now is just just think about you know
you will have been in
a tough situation before and you've
managed to get through it
um and it's like
uh it's not it's not helpful in the same
way that
it's not helpful to hear it'll be okay
and just pull yourself out of it
and it's more helpful to look at
something you can do about it that's
proactive
so that's where i got to reading but
just reading books and
just try to be careful what was lighting
in that was negative and to try and
drown out
the negativity with positivity from you
know some pretty well-known books and
um just resolve just remember that
you've um
remember that you've been in a bad place
before and you've found a way to keep
going
yeah good anchor point to have isn't it
or to anchor to that
yeah yeah and um yeah resolve to come
back stronger
amazing love that thanks for sharing
it's all right
so then you ended up investing in people
yeah recruiters yeah how did that come
about
and that came about because uh but kind
of quite accidentally really you know
um you know one or two people
uh that used to work for me um
you know for some for some reason wanted
something to do with me again
so uh you know i kind of
thought all right let's just try and
help help some people out and
uh one thing led to another i realized
um
i had more to offer in that regard than
maybe i realized quite enjoyed the
coaching side of it
and um it just felt right you know it
felt like um
a step forwards for me really at this
time teaching people do what i've done
type thing you know yeah for sure and
and how
so how just for how long have you been
doing that for now
i've been doing that uh for uh two two
and a half years
say yes and how many people have you got
involved with uh
i think there's currently seven
investments
about one or two other people in
slightly different ways and there was
one
that i invested in that didn't didn't
work
that's what you learned from yeah
exactly so let's just
talk about this for a second one thing
that i'd be really interested in
which is no doubt something that you'll
continuously learn
but obviously got quite a bit of
experience now but
what are the typical qualities you look
for
when selecting someone or
thinking about or getting to the point
where you're like right heisham you're
someone that i want to be involved in
what qualities do you look for would you
say all right well somebody
for me well make this what you will so
yesterday somebody
uh approached me with a person with as
an introduction
and my first question was
are they a nice person good question
right so that's it so um i can't be
asked dealing with top spot
yeah life's too short you know work with
people you know
the way it's set up at the moment
certainly the next the people i work
with now work with very kind of closely
and intensively you know
i'm all in with them and uh that's gonna
be the way in the case for the next
i'd say it's the next five people i
invest in so
i'm gonna you know don't we all one
thing's for sure
we've only got one life and so i you
know the people i invest in have to
share it with them
so i can't be bothered dealing with
idiots
you know people just aren't nice you
know yes that's the first thing
then they need to be intelligent they
need to be coachable
what makes someone more coachable and
can you um
imagine yourself
thinking one thing and being able
based on knowledge and fact to change
your mind
can you change your mind because if you
can't change your mind if you're just
gonna blindly dig your heels in
then uh too much pain
for me and for and for them probably
more for them
um but um i want to work with people who
want to find the
uh the the best way of doing something
not just their best way of doing thing i
like that
intelligence coachability what else
nice person i mean we talk about
resilience there before
and think about resilience is resilience
i think you the best way to get it is on
the job
and but what we've got to do we've got
we've got to look for people
who understand the amount of pain
that will be involved if they set off
on this path and that's if they want to
scale a business
right so there's no i've sent something
out to my investees this morning
which was basically like look uh
you know for for you guys to realize
your potential
you're probably gonna need you're prob
you're probably gonna um
uh have days when you're gonna lose six
figures worth of uh
deals in one day that you're expecting
to get
you probably you're probably you're
probably gonna lose your best biller
you're probably gonna have a situation
at some point where your best bill is
gonna basically
set up against you you know there'll be
betrayals in there people are going to
let you down people are going to be
doing all sorts on christmas dues
and uh you know yes another thing you're
going to get
is you're going to get more recessions
it might not be a pandemic but you're
going to get
loads more so if you're gonna go and set
your own business up you need to realize
that loads of [ __ ] is gonna happen and
that is how you get well
it's a combination you know um
like bad times shows who you really are
yeah but say it but in but in this in
the same way bad times
make who you are even better right so
i think what i'd say is it's like
everybody wants the um
baby without without the pain right
everybody wants to be the entrepreneur
right anyone and so many people can do
it that might not
if that's for the people i help now
somebody didn't think they could do it
in the first place
loads of people can do it if they want
to have the courage and give it a go
but you've gotta know you've gotta be
basically it's like you're gonna sign
yourself up for a serious amount of pain
but the great news is you will be a
better person not just a better
professional you'll be a better person
for it so i'm a big believer in that
that's part of the reason why i'm doing
this now is because i know
for me to execute on what i'm trying to
do i need to be a better
person than i was at the start of this
journey to make that happen
you know so uh i think some people think
it's a good idea to stay in the the
employed ranks and think that's safe i
think
another thing um that is
whether people like it or not uh it is
true
is having a job really the safest thing
your destiny in somebody else's hands
completely and utterly
i'd rather be um captaining my own [ __ ]
thank you very much
yeah nice it's an interesting point you
made that because i've i've
felt that for over the last year
business of just me
being only going for a year but the last
three months have really
sort of shown that to me that actually
being a
small agile
one person small business whatever
is uh actually a really strong position
to be in in in times of real adversity
and then at the same time being captain
your own
[ __ ] but having a lot of people on that
ship that's a whole different ass that
adds
whole different challenges but again you
still have control right which is what
you're talking about
and the full responsibility yeah i mean
i like the businesses i invest in i want
them to go for growth
right and i like to think that the
businesses i invest in you know they'll
be great businesses to work for it'll be
compelling reasons to stay there and be
retained
uh i think my point is a lot of people
won't go and start their own business
because of fear most commonly being
fear of failure but people will put
excuses out there
you know and yeah they're excuses uh
people will say things like
um you know it's safe i've got more job
security well
i remember talking about this in the
financial crisis
you haven't got job security how much
job security you really have gets
basically exposed in
uh crisis whereby you know if you work
for a bigger company
you one want one move loads of people
get cut
you know and you've got no control over
that so i think it's
taking a stoic and a balanced view of
job security if job security is the
reason for not going and doing it on
your own
well how secure is it really when the
gun gets tough
so the common fears that you see then is
job security
fear of failure anything else you think
that sort of you've noticed
is common or from the conversation you
had that have really prevented people
from taking the leap
fear mate just just it's fair and that's
dead normal
it's really really really really normal
but i thought i mean i've talked about
this quite a lot and i mentioned the
word there stoic i love reading about
the stomachs you know what i mean people
people there's a couple of great books
on that but um
people uh uh
you know are looking for looking for a
crystal ball what's going to happen
yeah what do we do about it actually one
of the smartest things you can do is
look 2 000 years that way
and look at what people like marcus
aurelius was we're talking about
which is is let solid
principles guide your decisions go back
2
000 years ago same [ __ ] was happening
people were terrified of change
right and that's the people you know
people uh
are more unfortunate as human beings
we're more motivated by what can go
wrong
when our threat system gets activated
than what can go right
yeah and uh tim ferriss he's a he's a
big
fan of history yeah he's awesome yeah
he's a big fan of the stoics and
and he looks upon decision making he
talks about making your decisions in a
stoic
way and stoic people think it just means
stipple lip and all that stuff but it
doesn't it actually means making a
balanced
decision so
when we look at maybe starting our own
business up
what most people will do is oh [ __ ] what
can go wrong
do you know what i mean that's what
everybody does but you did i did it i
know i did that you know
it's like oh and you're terrified about
what can go wrong
but actually especially for recruiters
the way the way
it's been advised to me that you should
be the stoic way of looking at that is
all right look if it goes wrong
what are the chances of it going wrong
having a permanent negative impact on
your life with the
key word being permanent because most
good recruiters if it goes wrong you're
not going to struggle again with a
decent recruitment job
right and but then what you've got to do
is after asking that is you've got to
ask the question
if it goes right what are the chances of
it having a permanent
positive impact on your life and i think
there all you've got to do is look at
all the people who
people like yourself people like me you
know as we discussed before i'm
completely unemployable anyway so i've
i've got to make this work um but
the permanent positive impacts you know
sure you've got the financial gear in
there
but it's also the sense of pride you
have them in what you're creating and
what your family feel about that and
you know if it goes right the likelihood
of that having a permanent permanent
positive impact on your life
is really really high so actually when
you balance up in a stoic
more often than not it's worth going for
it yeah no i like that
so let's just get into a few more sort
of granular things
what would you say from what you've seen
a conversation you had
would you say makes a market or a
business stroke person
more attractive than others uh
talent show talent short need for market
talent what do you mean talent show
available
availability of talent so um there needs
to be a shortage of candidates
in that area okay for you to go
yeah there's a good opportunity here why
does that make that more of a better
opportunity
ah right sorry i thought i thought you
talked about what market the recruiter
would be focused oh no sorry
so so what i was interested to get your
thoughts on is like what makes
so you've got two recruit two guys
speaking to you or ladies going hey mark
think about this
what do you think what would make one
more attractive than the other do you
think
typically just the person just the
person
how kind are they how driven are they
are they smart do they understand what
they're letting themselves in for
um and is it somebody that
uh want is it somebody wants to wants to
learn
you know if you've got all that you've
got the full you've got the full deal
and
oh and also all the other things you
have to check you have to check on other
things like
uh mindset when it comes to money
and things like that that's another way
people blow their own legs off
especially recruiters fully enough
what do you mean mindsets money and
people a lot of oh god you're getting on
this this guy i feel quite strongly
about it i don't know if it's
controversial or whatever but a lot of
recruiters have terrible money mindset
and the uh a lot of people would love to
hit the big time yet
will struggle because of what i call
lifestyle inflation so the more they
earn the more they just crank up their
own
overheads you've heard the concept of
delayed gratification
it makes sense in my head when you say
that okay so against the whole
instant gratification which is more of
the word that we're in
right instant gratification delay
gratification so this is something i'd
say to anybody
who's thinking about going for it it's
like
uh you know adhere to i love principles
you know i love
like the principles that again it would
have been principles 2000 years ago it's
like guess what
spend less than you earn how's about
that for a principal
right right put money aside for a rainy
day so you don't run out of money
you know again that's that's really the
people who've done that now are going to
be in a better position based on
by based on everything that's going on
but if you can delay gratification
and you're prepared to work hard enough
for long enough you will get there
if you are not if you want it all too
quickly then
you might just be if you're not willing
to invest in yourself and in growth
then you you may never hit the hit the
big time and
where i find that's interesting is i
think a lot of the time
um you know i wonder if recruiters are
sometimes intentionally bred to leverage
themselves up
to get the bigger car to get the bigger
house
and look big you know risby nice house
whatever you like you know i believe in
thinking abundantly go and get it if
that's what drives you go and get it
um i just wonder sometimes whether
people are led down that path
and encouraged to over leverage
themselves
so that they they they're on the hook
and have to keep billing
to that level to make the boss more
money
right and whether that gets you into
really really bad habits
whereas actually you know if you look at
um
people to achieve their true potential
very often they need to be working
towards a big
big purpose and very often that's
more than just money money's often part
of it money's important to me and
everybody else and why not you know you
want me to do certainly gives you more
choice you can do more with it
but like i think there has to be a point
where you
very often to get a business going you
have to invest in it right you know that
with your business you know you have to
sacrifice
you know you don't just very you know a
lot of the time you don't just start
your business and it's
you know you it's uh uh
you know it's it's at optimum success
level from day one very often you know i
remember when i when i
uh first started finley james uh
my dad lent me three grand well i think
it was three grand now
i had him paid back in a couple of
months and but i wasn't earning that
much to do it
i was willing to delay my own
gratification
and not go out and get the car and all
the rest of it to allow myself to keep
investing first in myself then in the
business
and then before you know it you're up
off and away and people will come say oh
you've done all right mate
but some people don't put it together
really it's like you've got to be
prepared to sacrifice
and delay your gratification if you want
to hit the big time
and i think a lot of the time and
anybody's willing to do that
and take pain and take the hits you can
do it
right no honestly i'm completely guilty
and it's something that
i always try and encourage people to
speak about on this because i think
it's really interesting what you say
because i think like way more
recruitment businesses will talk to
their employees about what they can
spend their money on
in terms of the material things etc
rather than how they can invest their
money
in to make them have better financial
quality
long term right and i think um
yeah it's come up quite a lot in this
podcast mark so i'm glad you brought it
up
the how many people sit down with you
once you've got that biggest paycheck
you've ever got
to say hey mark i'm not the guy to tell
you what to do with your money
but this is what i learned when i blew
my money and this is something to
consider
right and uh what's even to sort of
go a bit deeper on this and what's even
more
interesting about this i think and
spoken about this podcast a lot is that
what you find time and time again is
that when you do uh
get to that point where you can afford
that car or whatever it may be
that actually you feel empty and
it isn't as good as you hoped or it only
lasts for
a day or whatever and then as you said
you're then in that loop of
chasing the next thing or whatever and
that's why it's even more important as
well because
if you're then always chasing the
material thing the external thing and
then not feeling fulfilled you're
in even more trouble right so i think
there's layers to it and i'm really glad
that
you spoke about that so delayed
gratification is important if you're
serious about growing a real recruitment
business
yeah absolutely love that um just
so like what i wanted to say was how
important they're not talking about this
like
how you mentioned with your journey in
finney james but how important is it for
sort of recruiters to have a a pretty
solid business plan
when going out on their own how
important is that how is it important is
that to you when you're looking to get
involved and back people to
to go out on their own yeah
yeah i mean often yeah i'd say very
important if they're not if people
aren't capable of
um but i i don't think it's as important
that you go into the micro
in terms of you know knowing to the
nearest pound what you know linkedin
recruiter license will cost
but i think it's not that difficult to
project forwards what you're going to do
month-on-month sales
and you want to see ambition you know
three words that are in my mind that i'd
say a lot to the people i help at the
moment
what is possible what is possible
i think very often what we'll do when
we're putting those business plans
together
we'll you know we'll uh put limit our
own limiting self beliefs or our own
fear of failure will be reflected
in that business plan as people look to
play it safe i like
i like um there's a couple of ladies
i've invested in recently and honest to
god i just love their ambition
i just love it we're gonna go and do it
you know working you just started up in
a [ __ ] pandemic
and they just love it that's how much
they love recruitment and it's like you
know
there it starts like it's a bit tough at
the moment you know
don't care let's do it and they just
absolutely love it and they're really
ambitious and they're not letting
um circumstance external circumstances
beyond their control
impact their plan and they're going for
it and i just think that you know
they're looking to find out what is
possible as opposed to restricting
themselves with a plan so
business plan really important and i
like to don't
yeah but don't feel like yeah don't feel
like you need to be bogged down in the
micro
it's more about the mat like macro and
just be smart with
yeah where you want to be the vision and
obviously the
the core things that i guess are going
to contribute to you
how can you get there what's going to
make you different those things that are
important
um okay so you've mentioned it a couple
of times around
you want the people that you get
involved with to have the mindset of
wanting to grow their recruitment
business obviously not every
recruitment um business um
has to have that mentality of growing
[Music]
but the ones that you've ended up
involved in do or
that's something that you look for let's
just talk a bit about
how what do you what do you think has
been the sort of common
the um what's been one of the common
things that you've seen in the people
you've got involved in
that has helped them grow more
effectively
quickly than others do you think
drive and learning ability
uh
yeah that's that's the key that for me
that's the key thing
is how quickly can people learn
and how driven are they and can they
take
can they take the hits and keep moving
okay because the hits are inevitable
what do you mean by hits those those
things are getting people leaving you're
gonna get deals dropping out you're
gonna get you know that's the thing
that's
that's the thing that never ceases to
uh i forget about it you know it's like
you know you forget that
when you're helping a person who has
not ran their own business before you
know when you're talking about them
making
an investment uh you know
if i say to them right go deal with
heisham he should cos x
at the start that a lot of them are
still in the mindset that's like the
price of a holiday
it's not like that it's like value
tokens yeah it's
just what you do just go and do that so
it's basically thinking like a boss
quickly as opposed to with an abundant
mindset that's part of it
there's people who can do that quickly
and the taking the hits
it's yeah you know everything is
exaggerated when it's your own business
so if you get a deal that feels better
but if a deal goes the other way
then that feels a lot worse so it's been
able to basically
yeah i i think that's pr that's probably
the key thing actually
it's that it's that balance of
it's the emotion it's the emotional
regulation
so if you're too you know if you're too
kind of
you know where you get the deals coming
through if you're getting carried away
we all need a bit of that
but if that's too much then you might
well find that your low is
too low when you get a drop out or
you've had a bad month and from my point
of view when i'm working with people
like you just want the balance
consistency you want to celebrate every
little win
you know but you don't i don't want to
be picking people up off the floor every
time
it doesn't go the way away what about
just just a bit grinder here but it'd be
good to get your perspective on this
just because it's come up a lot on the
podcast it seems to be really common
in recruitment businesses at scale and
reading a really good book at the moment
that
sort of drums homeless message called
the emif which is like a proper
renowned business book which is great
and
um what i wanted to get your perspective
on is because something that i've seen
and always spoke
ended up speaking about is those
businesses that end up
growing end up scaling profitably in the
right way
they approach sort of how they what they
invest in their business in terms of
processes maybe even people
and in a way where they're thinking
about
before they're investing in things now
before they get there
if that makes sense so like if i'm if i
know i want to get to
20 25 heads or a certain net fee income
and i know to get me there i need an
operations person or i need
to document each process or whatever
instead of having the mentality of i'll
do that when or i'll do that when i get
to this point or whatever
people that end up scaling their
business do it today
and they does that make sense i don't
know what's your views on that
well you know my views on that you know
my startups get loaded in the year don't
we
so i i'm a big but you know the thing is
i think um i can't be asked anymore
messing around i've paid my entrance
fees you know what we're talking about
before
and i'd rather pay a bit of money
to save time especially when paying that
money is getting best in class people
like yourself
you know to help support that aspect of
a business so you know yeah i'm very
very on board with all of that what i
try and do is i'll try and make sure
they've got the best tech stack
locked and loaded day one you know and
they've got the best experts
uh uh whether it's you know the sales
consultancy or the branding consultancy
or you know
guys will my guys get assistance the uh
system they get pa day one your people
actually
have more support when they come and
start a business
with myself than they had working
for a bigger recruiting business where
they were sharing one marketer amongst
50 the other
marketing consultant as well so um i'd
like to give people
well i remember with that you see i was
always a fan of um i'm a manchester
united fan so i'm
sure that won't appeal to everybody but
anyway i remember alex ferguson
um talking about how he looked at his
best players almost like thoroughbred
racehorses and what he wanted to do was
give him everything
everything they could ever need so
there's no excuses
just like a thoroughbred racehorse that
basically live like kings
and i wanted to try and apply that
approach
to my thought was but if i can
get best in class people no pressure
adhesion to support them with those
aspects of their business from day one
then surely they should go further
faster
you know so uh yeah spend spend a couple
of quick get the best people
and just quickly on that because i think
it's really valuable i always like to go
into
particular things but just a quick one
like
what are the sort of non-negotiables for
you if i had limited resources limited
money
and you was to start a recruitment
business tomorrow what would be like the
non-negotiables that you would invest in
that
sort of you're taking that mindset of
like i want the best i want the things
now because i know it's going to help me
in the years time two years time
or whatever so what would be your
non-negotiables would it be
i'd have to get the tech stack right and
then i'd look to build on that would it
be the
i want to get the text out and the pa
support i don't know what what's what's
the sort of
negotiables for you do you think you
know the tech stats taking a little bit
of time actually
you know still working on that and
refining it but it's refining it now as
opposed to uh the start where i just
didn't know what i was doing
[Laughter]
marketing is the short answer mate
really yeah
okay all right marketing is the short
hand i'm not just saying that to
give you a big up but no that's
interesting
what about how important are processes
because i think that's
that's something that stands out for me
because if i think of my
my recruitment journey joined the
business survey sat down and shown in
the business
he shouldn't listen to me on the call
for a bit his you know what i mean i
think
again time and time again those
businesses that ended up in 40 50 plus
they documented each and every process
and like what how important is that
well look i should caveat of course
everything i've just said there that
you you know i'm taking it it's an
assumption that you're an amazing
salesperson
because it's the everything is about the
hustle so i'm looking at
making it giving you some extra stuff to
make you an even better sales person
getting more leads and all the rest of
it you know
uh but the
uh systems part of that um
yeah it needs to be repeatable 100
100 otherwise what you
so what what you want is you okay i was
chat something like this recently
what do you want you want rain makers or
do you want systems
you you kind of want both so you want
amazing sales people
machine operators who
are part of an amazing machine for me
that is optimum
so if you want like
one of the things i have absolutely i
must say this i mean hopefully it's
coming through i love what i do i look
because i just genuinely love helping
people
but also what i love doing is i'm on i
feel like
it's been great going back and rolling
the sleeves up and getting back involved
at the real kind of start up
on the grip what's going on you know
small recruitment company
and going back through these processes
and systems i've loved it
to find out what is the best way of
doing this
and i've not got the answers yeah but
there are so i think that's the key
point he said it's about making things
repeatable
because i think that i think if you
think early on and you i'm sure you've
seen this
when you're early on in a business when
you're early on in your recruitment
business it's so easy to let
those things um what's the word like
just let those things go and not think
about them because you think now
like i'll just you know i mean it's so
easy to not document your processes not
do those things
like no i'll just i'll do that later or
do you know what i mean and i think that
that's the part that's one of the most
important things
yeah that i keep getting from people
that well that's really interesting and
that's the thing you've got to from my
point of view like especially if i'm
putting money down
it's a tricky balance that because i
want my money back
you know to get a return on investment i
need to get the investment back first
and uh you've got to be conscious of if
you just
you know what you wouldn't want to do is
have somebody in a classroom for a month
solid
and interrupt the sales flow they should
know how
a recruiter should know how to with a
bit of support
you know should know how to go get some
deals in um
but on the same level yeah if people
want to scale a recruitment business so
what do you say is it ten percent or
something again
like i know like eighty percent of the
different different sources but you're
looking at a good
eighty percent of recruitment businesses
are sub 10 staff in the uk
yeah cool um well the ones that are
above that
are the people who will take systems
seriously
yeah and won't look at that's the thing
isn't it everybody
so when i when i one of the things i
help the people
i invest in with when it comes to their
plans
isn't just the business plan is we try
and have a look at what their life plan
is and inevitably people want to earn a
shitload of money
and have a load of time freedom both of
them need
systems yeah so uh
and the people who scale take that
seriously
they realize that and they invest time
into it
it might be deming or something like
that one of the old um
founding fathers of data what did he say
if you don't
if you don't find time to create systems
then you'll never have any enough time
something like that makes sense
okay so as we come to the end then
just couple sort of real just final
granular things on
investment because just just keen to get
your sort of honest take on this
i think from look from the lens that i
come from the conversations that i have
with recruiters different people
it seems like there's definitely not the
best reputation on
people or vehicles or businesses that
invest in recruiters
because typically you're hearing the
same sentence that they
they're there to take all your money or
they're there to sort of take most of
your company blah blah blah
right so just a few granny things
because i'd love to just get your
sort of honest account on it really
firstly
like how involved you getting how
involved you get in with the people that
you've
you i know it's different but the ones
that you've um got involved with the
most like how what what does that
actually involve like how involved you
actually get with your investees
ring me anytime ask me whatever you want
i'm in there with you whatever you need
okay and then how does this typically
work then
i know it'll be it'll vary but like are
we talking like what are you aiming to
take a decent percentage or what's
what's the typical way of structuring um
you getting involved in with an investor
right okay well that's my thing
so i i only want a minority share of
someone's business
so i think i think i think that's quite
unique um
i want it and just to be clear on that
what is actually what does that actually
mean
well everyone is slightly different but
of course
what rough percentage maybe like
modernity minority shareholder means
that one you're not yes you're not the
majority shareholder obviously
so but monitor shareholder means that
yeah you're okay
i just wanted to be clear that everyone
knows exactly what that means but yeah
so that could be what you could earn 10
it could mean you could own 20
whatever it may be yeah but they're all
you know
the more the more money you want will
affect the shareholding but there's a
rough rule of thumb if i end up with 25
i'm happy right and
uh my idea is
that um i will work with them
intensively
to get the foundations in they can have
all the systems all the tools all the
help
and then i end up with a relatively
passive state in their business
which i think uh is better
than having your ass owned by ruthless
uh people who uh you know the kind of
reception that you're talking about yeah
okay
interesting and then just just a quick
one i know it's like completely
subjective but like
what what what's your idea of like a
recruitment company that sort of
successful turnover profit-wise would
you say
i know it's completely subjective but
like what i don't know what would you be
really
i know everyone's different but like
typically what would you say is a decent
where would the recruitment business you
get for it to be in a decent
profitability mark and i think
you know what a lot of people talk about
if they want to they want a million
pound recruitment business
uh net free income you know i think
that's that's a really really good
um milestone to hit and someone messed
with the other day net fee income
yeah is your actual profits after you've
paid everything now i've also you paid
everything else yes
net fee income you'll typically hear
that or nfi
is is interested in the point that
you've raised actually is
you've got it's just like if it's perm
and there's
it's a 10 grand deal that's 10 grand nfi
but where that becomes useful is you can
you can
look at um what's the net fee and can
perfia
as a way of seeing how successful the
recruitment business is so
see if you've got a million quids worth
of sales
and you've got 10 uh recruiters
then that will be 100k net fee and
computer
then that will be a better business than
the same business that does
a million coins worth of net fee income
and it's got 20 people which would be
good with the net being so it's almost
the way of like uh about it batting
average you can use it to get the
batting average
yeah okay cool because i thought
yeah i just thought when i've spoken
about it before and spoke to people it's
yeah so
yeah if you i thought it was more about
if mark
so if mark's a recruitment business
owner and you build a million quid
that's your revenue and then your net
fee income
is the money that you at like the
profitability or is that just profit
profit net profit yeah net profit yeah
fair
because i think someone because i just
had someone messing about it recently
was like
he shouldn't heard this guy said nick
think i'm like i'm confused if i
actually understand what that is or
whatever but
i think people use it in different
contexts we do use in different contexts
and that's the other thing i'd say to
anybody that
like uh who is interested in starting
their own business
up you know there's nothing conceptually
difficult and don't be afraid
to ask what you might think is a stupid
question
right i ask them all the time stupid
questions and i'd rather
i just you know said uh
understanding and interpreting accounts
and stuff like that is something that i
remember when i started can feel a
little bit daunting there's worse yeah
well there's nothing out there's nothing
hard about them once you
just ask the right person a patient
person has been there
to spend a bit of time with you and make
sure you understand everything in
layman's speak
so before i ask you the last question
then yeah
final final words for people that
um fearful of starting on their own
what would you say to those people go
for it
i'd say what is possible those three
words
what is possible how are you going to
find out i love that
and are you going to real you know are
you going to realize you what you're
here to do you've got one life are you
going to give it a go or are you going
to have any regrets
that's what i'd say so final question
then is uh
i know you're probably touching it but
uh if if mark could
communicate to every single recruiter
out there
they'd listen to advice they'd take it
on and implement it tomorrow you could
sort of say a word phrase statement
sentence
what what would you say to the people
the people to to improve recruiters like
if you used to if
everyone could listen to mark and they'd
take on your advice
what would you say to them
educate yourself all the knowledge is
out there very often
it's like a tenner in a book someone's
complete knowledge
is in a book worth a tenner and it's
amazing you know so
you know keep learning and if you're
hungry enough
you'll get there mark's been a pleasure
all right mate yeah cool enjoyed the
chat haitian